hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash season 2 bonus video I'm
gonna be talking all about hunter
zolomon so just careful for spoilers if
you're not caught up on the flash season
2 yet there is a new round of the
giveaway - it's a $20 Amazon gift card
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so the big WTF is that it was
revealed by the showrunners the zoom is
hunter zolomon on the flash TV show now
this is really just the beginning
because we have to talk about what zooms
plan is on the TV show and how that
differs from the comic books because the
TV show collects from all eras of the
comics and we haven't really seen the
hunter so Lamont character in the comics
since flash rebirth like the very end of
that we see him talking to professor
zoom they're locked up in iron Heights
together and he says I have a plan we
can make each other better in the comics
that zooms whole mantra now essentially
he was the reverse flash of the wally
west era so he was like Wally West's
greatest enemy just like professor zoom
eobard thawne was Barry Allen's greatest
enemy so let's just start with the TV
show explainer for hunter zolomon we
already know quite a bit about him we
don't know about his motivation but we
know about his backstory we know that he
comes from Earth too because that's
where zooms surfaced but at the end of
episode 7 I think it was earlier this
season on the flash season - Jay Garrick
points to hunter zolomon in a park and
says this is the reason why you couldn't
find my earth-1 doppelganger because his
name isn't Jake Garrick his name is
hunter zolomon we know now based on what
the showrunners have told us that Jay
Garrick has been deceiving team flash
this whole time and it's been part of
zooms plan the showrunners explained
that Jay Garrick inserted himself in
team flash you know it's it's specific
roles relative to each character like a
love interest for Caitlin a mentor
figure for Barry
because zoom had been watching them ever
since the wormholes between earth 1 and
earth 2 opened at the end of season 1
for about six months and saw what they
needed most like the things that they
desired most so whatever his
relationship with this version of Jay
Garrick the one that he just killed and
dumped on the floor two really important
questions that have not been answered
yet one if hunter zolomon here is
masquerading as earth one Jay Garrick
where is the real earth one Jay Garrick
that's kind of why I think he might be
the man in the iron mask but number two
big question why does he want Barry
Speed so much why does he want to be the
fastest what what is he going to use
that
speed for it's not like he's Scrooge
McDuck and he's just gonna have a vault
where he's gonna swim around in
speedforce all day like just diving into
his money if there's anything the TV
show does it's developed complex
characters so there is something behind
zooms desire to get super fast now in
the comics hunter zolomon became the
zoom character because his body was
broken in this big gorilla attack but
Wally West refused to change the past to
fix his spine so hunter zolomon who was
a police officer kind of like Eddie went
to the cosmic treadmill tried to use it
to fix himself got in an accident and
that's what gave him his powers now in
the comics he doesn't technically use
the Speed Force the same way Barry does
he can control time in a more tactile
way so visibly his powers look like the
Flash's powers but the way they travel
in time is just a little bit different
zoom does that naturally the flash has
to run really fast to go backwards and
forwards in time the TV show hasn't
really explained the nature of zooms
powers why it is that he has blue
lightning and if his powers work exactly
the same as Barry Allen's I think for
the sake of simplicity his powers are
very similar to Barry Allen's but
there's some twists where he's not able
to naturally take Barry's speed he needs
Harrison wells to siphon the Speed Force
off and then he injects it into himself
like heroin so already the TV show is
way off comic book in terms of hunter
zolomon zoom they've incorporated some
things from the Jay Garrick era like the
velocity-9 formula that was something
created by the reverse flash of the Jay
Garrick era
his name was edward clariss he was just
called the rival in a rare moment of
honesty on the TV show Jay Garrick owned
up to Caitlin about how he lost his
speed
it was the formula that caused me to
lose it it didn't work right it damaged
my cells and I lost my speed but he did
take credit for creating the velocity
formula he just he took it to 16 flash
took it to 9 so there are a lot of
theories as to what the relationship
between earth - Jay Garrick enter -
hunter zolomon our zoom could be a TV
show version of cobalt blue in the
comics cobalt blue is named Malcolm
Thawne he's a long-lost twin of Barry
Allen who was taken by birth after one
of the thorns and raised as a Thawne his
childhood was terrible his parents were
con artists he had he had your typical
villain upbringing where he was
mistreated and abused as a child so he
grew
gain speed force powers through the use
of a talisman that gave him blue
lightning in sought to take Barry
Allen's life for his own as in this was
the life I was meant to have you took
everything that belongs to me the
problem with that on the TV show is the
motivation now whom could very well be a
twin of jay garrick's from earth to like
a long-lost twin from birth but at the
end of episode 15 when zoom dumps jay
garrick's body on the ground and says
this is a complication
he seems weirdly calm about it like oh
this is just a roadblock in my plan he
doesn't have that insane look in his eye
like eobard thawne always does so yes he
still does want to take all of Barry's
speed but maybe he has a plan to save
someone or something or himself or earth
to in general and he needs Barry's speed
to accomplish that way back before the
season started when we first saw the
blue flash I did a video about who is
the blue flash because there's a blue
flash from the new 52 comics but it
winds up being Barry Allen from the
future who wants to save the past and
feels like the only way he can do that
is to kill himself in the past so right
now I'm kind of split as to what's going
on with zoom one he's an actual physical
twin of Jay Garrick like a long-lost
twin cobalt blue style - he's Jay
Garrick from the future like a
post-apocalyptic earth to future he
feels like the only way to save the
future is to change the past and he
needs to take someone else's speed so
that he can move fast enough - right
whatever wrong there is the only things
we know about hunters Altamonte is that
he looks exactly like Jay Garrick and he
appeared within hours of the earth -
particle accelerator explosion
so really the origin of zoom on the TV
show just depends on how complicated you
think his backstory is they did say that
the answer would be satisfying it would
be meaningful and it would have
something to do with the man in the iron
mask so because so much of Barry's fight
with you Bart Thawne involves time
travel I feel like time travel doesn't
have a lot to do with Jay Garrick and
zooms story from Earth - remember the
story Harrison wells told about how soon
got his name he lured a bunch of police
officers into a trap killed them all
except for one so the one would go and
tell everyone that zoom was unbeatable
and there was nothing they could do to
stop him that feels vicious and
vindictive as if zoom is trying to
punish people for specific reason that
seems more like cobalt blue from the
comics
less like hunters Oh Lamont from the
comics hunters Oh Lamont had a noble
goal like he's I'm gonna make the flash
better but I have to cause him to feel
very specific tragedy comic book zooms
idea of tragedies like this calculated
used to make heroes better zoom on the
TV show doesn't seem like he cares about
that so right now for zoom I'm thinking
cobalt blue with a hunter zolomon name
you know like a long-lost twin who's
trying to punish everyone for the shitty
upbringing that he had now Jay Garrick
when he was telling Caitlyn about hunter
zolomon when he was still lying to
Caitlin about his doppelganger I think
he was honest about one thing that he
was adopted by his elements as a child
and raised by them that's why he has
their name that's why he doesn't have
the Garrick name I think that part of
the explainer was honest everything else
was a lie
hunter zolomon here really from earth-2
so the next big question if Jay Garrick
and hunter zolomon are both from earth-2
does that mean that there's still a Jay
Garrick in hunter zolomon from Earth one
the way the TV shows explained it so far
is that everyone does have a
doppelganger it's just that some of them
have died so you can still see it's
pretty complicated a lot of it depends
on the true origin of zoom on the TV
show and they didn't say they would
continue to tease that out but it's
gonna take the rest of the season to
find out who's underneath that metal
mask we are into some serious primer
on the flash season 2 right now I
really love it when things get
complicated but I actually I don't think
it's as complicated as we think it is I
think the TV show explainer will be a
little bit more elegant in its
simplicity and the one other thing that
we haven't really gone back to is the
alternate version of Barry telling Barry
from season 1 not to save his mother let
me know in the comments who do you think
earth to hunters Oh Lamont is do you
think that he's a physical twin
cobalt-blue style or do you think it's a
more complicated explanation but um I
know a lot of you have been asking me
about Supergirl
there was a Legion ring we saw a Legion
ring and Supergirl went team flash
travel through the wormhole to go to
earth 2 does that mean that the Legion
ring that we saw on the flash is the
Legion ring that we saw on Supergirl I
will say probably you know I don't think
the Legion ring is going to be the way
Barry gets to supergirls earth I think
they'll find a way to reopen a portal to
earth 2 because they have to find a way
to defeat zoom they can't do that if
they can't physically get to him so
eventually they'll find a way back to
earth-2
to reopen a portal and that will also be
the way that they get to supergirls
earth now the interesting thing about
the Supergirl episode the big crossover
episode is that it's gonna be Supergirl
episode 18 that's not that far away so
that makes me think the team flash is
gonna find a way to reopen a portal to
earth 2 in the next couple of episodes
most of you recognize Supergirl from
Smallville playing the Indigo character
in the comics she was created by
Brainiac 6 to go back in time and kill
Donna Troy within her was buried a
version of the Brainiac 8 program that
then took over her consciousness and she
kind of became Brainiac aids so she is a
version of Brainiac so I think that
eventually they might be able to do
Brainiac on the TV show it's always a
question as to what the TV show is
allowed to do because I feel like
Brainiac is a big enough villain to
appear in the movies and usually they
don't let movie villains appear on the
TV shows and I know a lot of you been
asking for Supergirl and Gotham videos
what I'm probably gonna do with those
going forward is just do those on
Facebook so I'll put a link in the
description it's just facebook.com slash
emergency awesome while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here to learn how some of Batman V
Superman got banned internationally it's
a ridiculous story and you can click
here for my Gotham mr. freeze video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight